Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Raumzeit. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist immer noch das tolle Projekt von ESA und DLR, wo wir mit vielen Leuten reden rund um Themen um die Raumfahrt herum. Und so soll es auch heute wieder sein. Der Weg hat mich heute ein weiteres Mal nach Darmstadt geführt zum ESAG. Und das Thema soll sich heute mal konkret auf eine noch aktive, aber auch schon seit längerer Zeit laufende Mission einschießen. Mal ein bisschen mehr in die Details einer konkreten Mission reingehen. Wir haben ja häufig auch Themen gehabt, die sehr umfassend sind und viele Missionen im Allgemeinen behandelt haben. Jetzt wie gesagt mal etwas konkreter. Und zwar wollen wir uns die Deep Space Missionen anschauen, die von der ESA gestartet werden, um Kometen zu erforschen. Und im Mittelpunkt steht dort vor allem Rosetta. Und dazu begrüße ich als Gesprächspartner für die heutige Sendung Gerhard Schwimm. Hallo.
Hallo.
Du bist schon eine Weile dabei, kann man sagen.
Das kann man so sagen. Ich bin also bei der ESA schon seit 1985. Also so langsam neigt sich meine Karriere zu Ende. Aber in der Raumfahrt habe ich schon ein bisschen früher angefangen. Ich hatte das Glück gehabt, schon während meines Studiums an einigen Projekten teilzunehmen. Ich habe Physik studiert und zunächst an der Universität des Saarlandes in Zabrücken begonnen und bin dann nach dem Vordeblom nach Bochum. Und dort bin ich mehr oder weniger durch Zufall dann in den Bereich extraterrestrische Physik gelangt, was schon sehr gut sich anhört und habe da begonnen, Staubforschung zu betreiben. Denn Staub nicht im Wohnzimmer, den man so sieht, sondern interplanetaren Staub. Und vom interplanetaren Staub kommt man dann sehr schnell zu den Kometen, weil eigentlich die Kometen ein Lieferant dieses Staubes sind. Und so hat es begonnen. Und das war Anfang der 70er Jahre.
Also wirklich früh dabei. Da hat man noch mit sehr eingeschränkten Mitteln arbeiten müssen im Vergleich zu dem, was heute so zur Verfügung steht.
Das stimmt. Aber auf der anderen Seite kann man sagen, dass ich dann sozusagen das Privileg hatte oder das Glück, so einige Entwicklungen mitzumachen. Wir haben sozusagen verhältnismäßig klein angefangen und man ist so dann dabei, wie sich die Entwicklung, so wie das so vorangeht. Und man lernt dann sozusagen auch sehr, sehr viel, weil man viel mehr noch in kleineren Projekten mit involviert ist. Das ist also nicht so, dass man so vom Management her kommt, sondern da muss man, wie man so schön sagt, auch noch den Schraubenzieher und den Lötkolben manchmal benutzen, um Dinge zu tun. Und das hilft einem, um Dinge zu lernen. Das ist dann learning by doing.
Ja, auch um so ein umfassenderes Verständnis für die Anforderungen an der solchen Mission zu bekommen. Später mündete das dann auch konkret in Missionen. Und unter anderem warst du, wie heißt das so schön, Head of Solar System Science Division.
Head of Solar System Science Operations Division, das ist das, was wir jetzt machen, wo wir zuständig sind für das Management der Missionen, wenn sie gestartet sind. Vorher wird das ja von unseren Kollegen bei SDEC gemanagt, die aus dem Projekt-Department kommen. Und ich war jetzt die letzten vier Jahre Head of Solar System Science Operations Division. War aber zuvor, bevor wir durch interne Organisation das Department geteilt hatten, war ich der Head der Planetary Missions Division. Also da die ganze Zeit sozusagen mitverantwortlich für die Mission der ESA im Sonnensystem und jetzt vor allem für die Operations und das Management. Also ich habe die ersten 20 Jahre oder 22 Jahre meiner Karriere bei der ESA in SDEC verbracht und bin dann vor vier Jahren nach Madrid, weil die ESA hat ja verschiedene Zentren über Europa verteilt und es gab vor einigen Jahren die Entscheidung, dass also auch etwas mehr Aktivitäten nach Spanien verlegt werden sollten. Und als Konsequenz wurde dann die Solar System Science Operations auch nach Spanien gebracht in das Zentrum, das jetzt ESAC heißt, in der Nähe von Madrid. Das war vorher eigentlich ein Zentrum für die Astronomie-Mission. Es fing mit IUE an und dann wurden also Science-Oberations der Astronomie-Missionen hinzugefügt und inzwischen auch die Sonnensystem-Mission. IUE, das International UV Explorer. Das war eine der Veteranen-Missionen der ESA, die also auch sehr, sehr lange gelebt hat. Es war ein Gemeinschaftsprojekt mit NASA und den Engländern.
Die Fähigkeit, solche Deep Space-Missionen zu machen, das musste ja auch erst mal entwickelt werden. So mit der Zeit, womit begann das eigentlich?
Das begann bei der ESA eigentlich mit Giotto. Giotto war sozusagen unsere erste interplanetare Mission. Und man musste ein bisschen in der Geschichte der ESA zurückgehen. Das war noch sozusagen vor meiner Zeit, aber man schaut sich ja ein bisschen die historische Entwicklung an. Die ESA hat sich eigentlich ursprünglich auf Missionen in der Erdbahn sozusagen beschränkt. Anfangsjahr an der ESA war eigentlich gar keine Pläne, um dann interplanetare Missionen zu machen, sondern man hat sich erstmal auf den erdnahen Weltraum beschränkt, um da auch die Erfahrung zu gewinnen. Und dann, als der hellische Komet wieder mal sozusagen aufgetaucht ist, der hat ja eine Umlaufzeit von 75, 76 Jahren, ist ja der berühmte Komet, da... Obwohl es nicht der Stern von Betlehem ist. Ist er nicht? Nein, nein, man assoziiert es immer damit, aber da gibt es andere Konstellationen. Das war wahrscheinlich mehr eine besondere Konstellation der Planeten, die dann so aussehen. Ja, ja, aber es wird assoziiert, weil die Kometen überall auftauchen, auf Bildern über der Krippe und so ähnlich. Also da gibt es schon die richtige Assoziation. Und als es war, hatten die Amerikaner zu der Zeit auch den Plan, endlich mal eine Kometenmission zu machen, um einfach mal zu diesen primitiven Objekten zu gehen. Und das war auch eine Gemeinschaftsaktivität mit der ESA. ESA sollte auch da ein kleines Raumfahrzeug mit dazu liefern. Die Amerikaner konnten das dann im Endeffekt nicht machen. Dann hat der damalige ESA-Direktor Ernst Rendenburg entschieden, er macht das selbst. Und da kann man schon fast sagen, dass er das selbst macht. Er hat es also durchgedrückt, dass dann die ESA eine Mission zum helligen Kometen macht, das was dann später Giotto wurde. Und da wurde also in einem Rekordtempo zu dieser Zeit, und das war Anfang der 80er Jahre, wo die ESA keine Erfahrung mit interplanetaren Missionen hatten, wurde Giotto gebaut. Und ich meine, da hat man einen festen Zeitpunkt gehabt. Da konnte man sich also keine Verzögerung erlauben. Man musste das starten, weil der Komet 86 nah an der Sonne vorbeifliegen würde und das war sozusagen der Startschuss für die Planetenforschung in der ESA. Das hat auch die ESA sozusagen mit einem Schlag an die vordere Front der Planetenforschung gebracht und hat demonstriert, dass wir das auch können. Das sollte man als wichtigen Aspekt sehen. Zu der Zeit waren wir in der Planetenwissenschaft und ich kann mich noch gut erinnern, noch zu meiner Zeit an der Universität, dass es hier in Europa hatten wir Treffen, wo man dann überlegt hat, wie kann man also etwas mehr für die Planetenforschung in Europa machen, weil wir da einfach den Amerikanern hinterher gelaufen sind. Die hatten damals die Pioneermission, sie hatten Voyager gestartet, also wunderbare Projekte und wir wollten natürlich auch was machen und unsere Wissenschaftler und dann auf einen Schlag haben wir dann Giotto bekommen. Und man muss ja auch erinnern, dass zu der Zeit auch Cassini- Huygens begann, eine andere NASA-ESA-Kollaboration. Die Mission zum Saturn. Die Mission zum Saturn, die sehr erfolgreich war. Das kommt alles zusammen. Das war also sozusagen der Staat, der uns sozusagen dazu gebracht hat, mal wirklich was Neues zu machen und hier auch den europäischen Wissenschaftlern die Chance gab, auch sich in der Planetenforschung jetzt eigenständig zu profilieren.
Planetenforschung und speziell auch Kometen waren ja hier bei Raumzeit auch schon ein Thema. Mittlerweile haben wir schon so viele Sendungen beisammen, dass es sich glaube ich mal lohnt, auch immer mal wieder nach hinten zu verweisen. Also die fünfte Ausgabe hat sich explizit mit dem Aspekt Planetenforschung auseinandergesetzt. Das Gespräch mit Ulrich Köhler und aus dem selben Institut, aus dem selben Institut für Planetenforschung des DLR mit Ellen Harris ging es um Asteroiden und Kometen in der neunten Ausgabe. Aber was wusste man denn damals schon über den hellischen Kometen? Also hatte man eigentlich schon eine relativ klare Vorstellung davon, was einen so erwartet oder waren dann die wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse dieser Missionen überraschend?
Ja, wir hatten Ideen, was ein Komet ist. Da hat sich ja in den, sagen wir, in den Jahren von 1950, als Fred Wippel seine Theorien vorbrachte, auch in Deutschland mit Ludwig Biermann, dem Direktor des Mark-Bank-Instituts in München, hatten wir ja auch herausragende Kometenwissenschaften, auch hier in Deutschland vor allem. Und da wussten wir so ungefähr, was ein Komet ist. Wir hatten eine Vorstellung. Es gab immer noch zwei Theorien einfach. Einmal, dass der Kometen ein Kern war, also ein festes Gebilde, Wasser und Staub gemischt, also Eis und Staub gemischt. Und wenn dann die nähe Sonne kommt, wieder aufgeheißt, dann sublimiert das Eis das Gas und das nimmt dann so den Staub mit. Und dann bildet sich dieses wunderbare Phänomen aus, dass man als Kometen den Kern, kann man ja nicht sehen, von der Erde. Der ist zu klein. Der sitzt auch in der Koma dann. Und dann hat man den Staub und Gas schweift. Das wusste man schon. Und dann gab es noch die sozusagen konkurrierende Theorie, die damals also schon so ein bisschen auf der Seite mitlief. Das war dann, dass man also ein, wie so eine Sandbank im Weltraum hatte, dass man einfach die die Staubteilchen, wie wenn man ans Meer geht, an den Strand, dass diese Staubte, dass der Sand am Meer liegt, dass der einfach zusammenklebt und dass das sowas durch das Weltall fliegt. Wir hatten da also, wir hatten da schöne, wir hatten da gute Modelle, hatten gewisse Vorstellungen auch über die Zusammensetzung dann des Materials und Kometen. Und das war aber auch sozusagen die große Herausforderung, dass wir natürlich mehr lernen wollten und wir wollten auch endlich mal einen Kometen- Kern, den Nukleus, den wollten wir mal sehen. Es ist gut zu sagen, ja nach der Theorie sitzt da der Kern da, aber wir können da natürlich von der Erde, selbst mit den großen Teleskopen zu der Zeit, konnte man das nicht auflösen, weil die Dinge sind meistens nur ein paar Kilometer im Durchmesser. Und wenn es näher an die Sonne herankommt oder näher auch zur Erde, sitzt er dann in der Koma, weil einfach das Gas dann weggeht und das ist das, was also der Sonnenlicht dann reflektiert und was erleuchtet. Das war ein Punkt und das andere, das zweite noch mal zurück auf die Bedeutung der Kometen. Wir meinen ja, dass die Kometen sozusagen die Materien beinhalten im Zustand, wie sie damals bei der Entstehung der Sonnensystems vor 4,6 Milliarden Jahren war. Dass also das sozusagen für uns das Fenster ist, um zurückzuschauen, aus was wir uns, also die Planeten, sich entwickelt haben. Das waren alles Dinge, die man wusste. Das andere, was dann ein richtiger, wichtiger Auslöser war, ist natürlich, dass Halley der bekannteste Komet eigentlich ist. Der ist also durch, der ist schon über, kann man sagen, Jahrtausende beobachtet worden. Und er war 1910 sehr nah an der Erde vorbeigeflogen. Wenn man sich jetzt sozusagen Geschichtsbücher anguckt, es gab damals schon fast, kann man sagen, Hysterie, dass wir durch den Kometen schweift durchfliegen. Der war also viel näher an der Erde. Und die Erde hat sich sozusagen durch den Kometen schweift bewegt. Und da gab es also die große Gefahr, dass da giftige Gase in der Kometen, in dem Kometen schweift wären und dann, dass man also durch Cyanit sozusagen Vergiftung bekommen könnte und alles. Und dass dicke, steinsbrockene, Staubsteine auf die Erde fallen würden, die vom Kometen losgehen. Und dass man also da sich Häuser getroffen werden, Autos und alles. Da gibt es also wunderbare Karikaturen zu der Zeit. Das heißt, es gab da schon sozusagen auch in der, das war damals diese Comics, war fast wie diese Boulevard-Zeitungen heute. Es gab da schon, 1910 war das ein ziemlicher, sagen wir es schreckend, ziemlicher Hype. Und für viele Leute war das im Kopf, man sagt ja auch immer, der Halley ist sozusagen ein Lifetime-Common, Lebenszeit-Common. 75, 76 Jahre ist so eigentlich die Lebenszeit eines Menschen.
Jeder sieht ihn einmal.
Jeder sieht ihn einmal, ja. Und wir haben auch Leute gehabt, zum Glück, die wir dann also 85 interviewt haben, die den hellischen Comedian zweimal gesehen hatten, die halt einfach als Kind noch die Erinnerung hatten, waren dann 80 Jahre und so. Aber die haben auch bestätigt, dass das damals war, das ein Superereignis. Und das hat auch geholfen zu sagen, das wollen wir jetzt näher erforschen und so eine Mission dann auf die Beine zu bringen. Dann hat man, man muss immer so sein Ziel haben. Und das zeigt sich auch, dass wenn man ein gutes Ziel hat, wo man dann also auch alles dran aufhängen kann, begründen kann, was man macht, hilft auch ein bisschen, die Unterstützung zu bekommen, um diese Dinge zu machen. Und das war einfach, es war der richtige Zeitpunkt, so was zu machen. Und wir müssen auch sagen, dass es von der ESA damals auch die richtige Entscheidung war, diese Mission zu machen. Das war ein Riesenrisiko, weil wir hatten keine Erfahrung mit diesen Missionen. Es war auch ein Riesenrisiko mit der Zeit, die man noch hatte, um diese Mission einfach auf die Beine zu stellen, die Instrumente zu bekommen. Und ich weiß, da ging ich damals noch aus der Universität heraus. Das war gerade meine Transfer zur ESA. Einige Instrumente, da war ich mit beteiligt. Und da waren wir schwer unter Zeitdruck, um Dinge zu machen und auch neue Dinge zu machen. Auch Instrumente, die man noch vorher nicht gebraucht hat, weil man einfach Staub in dem Sinne, die nicht studiert hat mit der Zusammensetzung, dass man die schnell auf die Beine gestellt hat. Das war schon interessant und es war eine Riesenherausforderung.
Die Mission war dann aber auch erfolgreich.
Und zum Glück war die Mission dann auch erfolgreich.
Also das Start hat geklappt, das glaube ich mit einer Ariane 1.
Das war die letzte Ariane 1, die noch eingemottet war. Der hat geklappt und auch auf den Tag genau. Das war also mein erstes öffentliches Auftreten bei ESOK. Ich war also als stellvertretender Projektwissenschaftler. Dann wurde ich gleich da ins kalte Wasser geschmissen, weil wir damals ein ganz kleines Team hatten. Das habe ich dann bei ESOK den Start mitverfolgt. Das war also schon mal etwas Interessantes. Und dann die Nacht des Kometen, also der 13. und 14. März 1986. Das war schon ein riesiges Ereignis hier bei ESOK. Alle Experimentatoren waren hier mit ihren. Teams. Es waren natürlich sehr viele VIPs hier und auf dem Gelände war dann ein Zelt aufgebaut für die Angestellten der ESA. Das muss man realtime mitmachen. Und es war ein riesen Medien-Zirkus, also zu der Zeit, obwohl es noch nicht so viel Privatfernsehen gab. Weltweit hatten wir Fernsehstationen hier, also von Japan, Amerika hierher. Und man muss ja sagen, dass das im Endeffekt nachdem ESA die Entscheidung getroffen hatte, haben dann also die Russen, damals noch Sowjetunion, auch zwei ihrer Missionen, die sie schon geplant hatten, zur Venus, die hatten sie dann so ein bisschen umdesigned, dass die also an der Venus vorbeifliegen konnten und dann zum Hellischen Kometen gehen, um auch da Messungen zu machen. Und auch unsere Kollegen in Japan hatten zwei Missionen geplant, die ein bisschen weiter weg vom Halley vorbeigeflogen sind, aber die gehörten sozusagen zu dieser Armada von Raumfahrzeugen, die den Hellischen Kometen besucht hatten.
Aber keiner ist so nahe gekommen wie Giotto?
Nein, keiner ist so nahe gekommen. Also das war die große Herausforderung. Und das war also auch das, was wir haben wollten, oder was die Wissenschaftler wollten, so nahe wie möglich vorbei, um dann wirklich ganz nah am Kometen messen zu können, einfach den Kometen in hoher Auflösung zu sehen. Je näher man rangeht, desto mehr Details sieht man. Aber zweitens, weil wir die Theorie, wir wussten, was so passiert, wir wollten auch die Zusammensetzung der Koma, die wollten wir auch genau studieren, weil wenn sozusagen Moleküle... Koma ist das, was direkt um den Kometen herum ist und dann der Schweif, das ist das, was sozusagen weiter weg, was weggetragen wird und da gibt es halt den Plasma und den Staubschweif. Aber die Koma ist sozusagen der Kokon, wo der Nukleus drin sitzt, das ist einfach das, wo der Staub rauskommt, das ist so ein paar tausend Kilometer, kann man sagen, je nachdem, wie man die Dichte betrachtet. Und da wollten wir aber rein, weil wir wollten sehen, welche Prozesse gehen da drinnen vor. Da gibt es also gewisse Dinge, die wollten wir studieren und da war sozusagen das Prinzip, je näher, desto besser und auch mit dem Risiko, dass es könnte sein, dass Giotto die Sonde von einem Staubteilchen getroffen wird, dann kann es vorbei sein. Dafür haben wir also auch ein Schutzschild vorne dran gemacht, also gebaut. Das basiert auf der Theorie, dass man also die Staubteilchen, wenn sie da einschlagen, dass die dann einfach auch selbst zerschlagen werden und statt eines großen Staubteils kommen dann nur noch Brocken auf die nächste Schicht. Und man musste also genau mit der richtigen Richtung da reinfliegen, dass das Giotto geschützt war und die Instrumente haben also sozusagen um diesen Schutz rumgeguckt, da war schon die Gefahr. Ich meine, wenn man irgendwo hingucken kann, kann man keinen, weiß nicht, zumachen. Das waren Dinge, die man überlegen muss. Das waren alles neue Dinge. Das war ein mehrstufiger Schutzschild, also ein zweistufiger in dem Fall Schutzschild. Das war schon wichtig, da auch zu überlegen, wie muss man den auslegen, dass man also den größtmöglichen Schutz hat, ohne da jetzt Tonnen von Material zu fliegen. Das waren so die kleinen Herausforderungen. Das war eigentlich der Einstieg, wo ich mit reingekommen bin, weil, wie gesagt, ich habe sozusagen Staubforschung betrieben und da konnten also diese Kenntnisse mit reingehen und ich habe dann noch, zu meiner Zeit, als ich bei der Universität war, war ich dann ein Mitglied dieser Gruppe, die sich mit der Staubumgebung des Kometen beschäftigt hat und ich habe dann mit meinen Kollegen, das war also in Heidelberg, mein Max-Planck-Institut, die ja weltweit führend waren auf dem Gebiet der Staubexperimente, mit dem konnte ich dann also auch zusammenarbeiten bei den beiden Staubexperimenten, die von Heidelberg mit entwickelt wurden.
Wie lange dauerte die Reise von Giotto?
Ja, also wir haben dann, im Juli war der Start, Beginn Juli 1985 und im März waren wir da. Also das ging flott. Ratze fatze, weil das war ein Vorbeiflug. Und wie nah ist er ihm dann wirklich gekommen? Wir sind zum Schluss so knapp unter 600 Kilometer vorbei.
Das ist so in astronomischen Dimensionen schon.
Nichts, fast ein Volltreffer. So war es auch geplant und da gibt es also auch...
Warum geht man nicht... Also ich meine, wie bestimmt man denn diesen Abstand, den man eigentlich haben will? Man hätte ja auch sagen können, ach das Ding kommt eh nicht wieder. Gehen wir doch mal da richtig nah ran.
Naja, da gibt es... Das ist eine schwierige Frage. Und da könnte man also, ich habe schon damals gesagt, da hätte man einen wunderbaren Comic drehen können oder schreiben können, wie das dann entschieden wurde. Aber es gibt zwei Dinge. Ich meine, erstens, wenn sie vorbeifliegen, es ist ja sehr, wir wollten ja den Kern mit hoher Auflösung fotografieren. Und das wurde immer so zum Beispiel gebracht, dass man also in der Concorde zu der Zeit sitzt und dann also ein Foto machen will. Und dann müssen sie ja ihr Fotoapparat auch nachführen und zwar sehr schnell nachführen. Und das war also eine der Herausforderungen. Sie können sehr nah vorbei, aber dann muss die Kamera sehr, sehr schnell schwenken. Weil das Raumfahrzeug war ein spinnstabilisierter Satellit. Der hat sich also um seine Achse gedreht, das Schild nach vorne. Und jetzt rasen wir an dem Kometen vorbei und der rotiert da. Dann sitzt also eine Kamera drauf, die muss also genau die Rotation des Satelliten kompensieren und muss sich dann ganz schnell drehen. Wir fliegen auf das Objekt zu, kommen da lang, dann muss ich natürlich das verfolgen und dann gucke ich sozusagen nach hinten. Und da wir mit 68 Kilometer pro Sekunde vorbeigeflogen sind, kann man sich vorstellen, dass das schon eine große Herausforderung war.
Was hat denn vorbeigeflogen? Also man hat nicht dieselbe Bahn eingenommen wie der Kometen. Nein, das war eigentlich ein Aufeinander-Zufliegen.
Das war ein Aufeinander-Zufliegen, weil die große, das Besondere an Kometen-Halley ist, dass der auf einer retrograden Bahn ist. Das ist also eine Bahn, die nicht in dieselbe Richtung, wie die Erde um die Sonne rumgeht, sondern gerade in gegengesetzte Richtung. Das heißt, es war wie, wenn also zwei Autos sozusagen aufeinander zurassen, dass man dann sozusagen einen Frontalzusammenstoß hat. Und das wäre es dann gewesen.
Das heißt, man hatte sozusagen, zumindest mit dieser kurzen Flugzeit hatte man keine Möglichkeit, jetzt dieselbe Richtung einzunehmen.
Nein, das hätte man.
Weil man fliegt sozusagen von der Erde weg. Dann hat man im Wesentlichen erst mal die Geschwindigkeit der Erde und bewegt sich auf den Kometen zu. Hätte man jetzt hinter dem Kometen hinterherfliegen wollen, hätte man einen ganz anderen Weg nehmen müssen.
Da hätte man einen ganz anderen Weg. Und das wäre auch heute nicht möglich. Also mit der Energie, die dann möglich ist, um die Bahn zu ändern. Weil die Erdbahn geht 30 Kilometer pro Sekunde, ist die Bahngeschwindigkeit der Erdbahn. Und wenn sie das jetzt ändern wollen in eine Bahn, die sozusagen in die andere Richtung geht, dann brauchen sie schon 60 Kilometer pro Sekunde. Weil sie einfach das ganze Ding umdrehen müssen. Und das ist auch selbst bei Rosetta, wo wir zum Komet gehen, der also auf einer Brokratenbahn ist, da brauchen wir ja sehr lange. Und das hat mit zu tun, dass wir also wirklich Bahnenergie uns holen müssen, damit wir uns also synchronisieren können mit der Bahn des Kometen. Und wenn man das bei Halley gemacht hat, dann wird das einfach, das geht eigentlich technisch gar nicht.
Also das war einfach nicht denkbar. Das heißt, man musste damit leben, dass man quasi auf diesen Bus zufährt.
Ja, und dann gucken schnell also vorbei. Und in der Zeit, wo man so vorbeifliegt, dass man dann also ein Bild macht. Oder einige Bilder.
Dann hat sich dann der Satellit dabei gedreht sozusagen?
Nein, der Satellit fliegt immer in die Richtung. Weil wir sind ja durch die Koma geflogen. Also wir hatten ja den Schutzschild sozusagen vorne am Saal. Und das Raum, auch das konnten wir nicht drehen, sonst hätten wir überall das Spacecraft schützen müssen. Sondern wir sind da also so durchgefahren. Die Richtung, aber die Kamera, die hat sich gedreht. Und die hat dann das Bild gemacht. Und da hängt es halt immer davon ab, wie schnell sie so eine Kamera drehen können. Sonst kriegen sie natürlich ein verwichtetes Bild. Das kennt jeder, der mal sozusagen ein Sportfoto macht, wenn dabei irgendein Skiläufer vorbeirast.
Wie schnell musste sich denn dann die Kamera drehen?
Die, das ist, innerhalb von drei Sekunden muss die, glaube ich, wieder nach hinten gucken.
Das heißt, hätte man entschlossen, noch näher ranzufliegen, wäre diese Drehgeschwindigkeit noch viel größer gewesen.
Das heißt, der Abstand, den man haben will, ist quasi der Kompromiss, dass man die Verzerrung minimiert oder überhaupt keine Verzerrung kriegt. Dass man das machen kann, das hängt ja auch mit zusammen. Das waren also derzeit, das war die erste Kamera mit einem CCD-Chip, also die erste wissenschaftliche Kamera, sagen wir mal so.
Wir wissen nicht, ob die Technik, die man heute in jeder Digitalkamera findet.
In jeder Digitalkamera war das erste Mal im Weltraum für das, dass man also ein CCD-Chip hatte. Und durch das, was sehr schnelle Bilder auslesen wollte, waren noch viele Tricks angewendet worden. Und das muss man also auch sich im Kopf behalten. Und Sie wissen ja selbst, wenn Sie CCD-Aufnahme machen, wenn jemand den Kopf gerade bewegt, das ist auch heute mit den modernen Chips, die schon viel schneller sind, muss man schon noch aufpassen, dass man da also kein, dass es nicht verwischt ist.
Was war die Auflösung?
Na ja, das kommt darauf an, wie weit man weggeflogen ist. Was wir also zum Schluss gekriegt haben, waren also die besten Bilder, die waren etwa so in der Größenordnung von 60 bis 80 Meter. Und da muss man noch dazu sagen, wir haben kein Bild machen können, als wir nah dran waren, weil die Kamera schon vorher getroffen wurde. Also das letzte Bild ist nicht bei 600 Kilometer Entfernung gemacht worden, sondern bei etwa 2000 Kilometer Entfernung. Wir sind da rangeflogen und dann ging auf einmal sozusagen der Hagelsturm los. Hagelkörner waren da Staubteilchen und die Kamera ist getroffen worden. Und die hat dann ein Reset gehabt. Also das letzte Bild ist etwa aus 2000 Kilometer Entfernung gemacht worden. Sonst hätten wir eine Auflösung von so ungefähr 20 bis 40 Meter gehabt. Und das war das letzte Bild. Da könnte man jetzt im Nachhinein sagen, warum habt ihr diese wunderbare Auswahl getroffen, bei 600 Kilometer vorbei zu fliegen, wo das Risiko so groß war, wie der besser bei 2000 Kilometer geblieben hätte, eine Chance gehabt, noch länger Aufnahmen zu machen. So Dinge, das weiß man dann hinterher besser. Aber wir haben, also das war schon gut, dass wir so nah dran gegangen sind. Aber man muss ganz ehrlich sagen, und das sieht man auch in den Bildern, die veröffentlicht wurden, dass also die letzten Aufnahmen, wie gesagt aus einer etwas größeren Entfernung, 2000 Kilometer, war immer noch viel näher dran, als die Russen das gemacht haben. Die waren bei 8000 und wir haben da also die Bilder von Halley, das war ja damals sozusagen das Prototyp eines Kometen, das erste Bild des Nucleus. Das war schon interessant, war ja auch fast 15 Jahre das einzige Bild, was wir von einem Kometen kennen hatten.
Und was konnte man dann auf den Bildern sehen?
Was also wirklich überraschend war, ist, dass der Kometenkern sehr dunkel war. Das heißt, der hat sehr viel der Strahlung, die da drauf fällt, absorbiert. Und der war eigentlich schwerzer, um das mal salopp zu sagen, als wir uns das vorgestellt haben. Das war also die erste Überraschung. Die zweite Überraschung war, dass der Kern nicht über die ganze Oberfläche sozusagen aktiv war, sondern dass es aktive Gebiete auf der Komenten-Oberfläche gab und es gab Gebiete, die mehr oder weniger ruhig oder inaktiv sind. Das war die zweite Überraschung. Wir hatten eigentlich gedacht, dass der Komenten-Kern über die ganze Oberfläche sein Gas und Staub los wird. Aber das war, dass man da also wirklich sehr beschränkte, aktive Gebiete auf der Oberfläche identifizieren konnte. Und ich meine, da gehen sozusagen Chats von Staub und Gas raus. Das war das. Und das andere war, dass wir also etwa die Form haben, dass das so die Amerikaner sagen, Peanuts, weil sie mehr mit Peanuts sozusagen vertraut sind. Man kann auch sagen, dass es mehr so eine Kartoffelform war, diese unregelmaße Form war. Keine Überraschung, aber zumindest hat man das jetzt mal gesehen, dass da ein fester Kern war. Und dann auch, dass also sehr, ja, Oberflächenstrukturen sehr deutlich zu sehen waren, dass man also da sozusagen Berge und Täler gesehen hat, also tief, tief eben, dass das doch eine sehr strukturierte Oberfläche war. Weil sonst würden sie ausgehen, wenn sie so einen Schneeball haben und der so langsam sublimiert draußen, dann bleibt der ziemlich rund, also da gibt es nicht so viel Form. Also das war schon überraschend. Also das war das eine, jetzt von den Bildern her. Das zweite war natürlich diese Messung der Zusammensetzung der Moleküle, da das da also ein sehr großer Reichtum von sehr komplexen, komplizierten Moleküle zu finden ist. Nicht nur einfach Wasser und ein paar ganz einfache, sondern dass da also schon größere komplexe Moleküle zu finden sind im Kometen. Und auch beim Staub, dass man diese sogenannten PHAs gefunden hat, also diese Polycyclic-Aromatik Hydrocarbons, also sehr komplizierte Moleküle, die also in die Richtung, und da muss man aufpassen, was man sagt, wir haben die dann als John-Particles bezeichnet, das heißt CHON, also Kohlenstoff, Wasserstoff, Stickstoff. Das sind eigentlich die Bausteine, die man braucht, wenn man also Leben erzeugen will. Und dass da also diese John-Particles da drin waren, also nicht ganz klar gesagt, wir haben also keine Formen von Leben gefunden, sondern wir haben eigentlich die Bausteine gefunden, dass die als Teilchen da drin waren, in den komplexen Molekülen, die man braucht, um irgendwann mal, wenn man Leben entstehen lassen möchte, dass die sozusagen im Ursprung da sind. Das sind so ganz knapp gesagt ein paar der großen Überraschungen.
Das heißt, man hatte quasi auch Futter für die These gefunden, dass die Kometen ein bisschen auch die Bringer des Lebens sein könnten?
Das könnte man so ausdrücken. Ich bin da ganz vorsichtig. Ich meine, das gibt ja so Theorien, dass die Kometen in der Anfangsphase der Erde, haben wir ja sehr viel mehr Kometen gehabt, die auf die Erde eingeschlagen sind, weil einfach unser Weltraum um uns herum noch nicht so sauber war. Da sind also sehr viele rein. Wenn man dann sagt, da kommen komplexe Moleküle und sie haben also auf der Erde das Wasser, was wir auf der Erde haben, sie haben gewisse Temperaturbereiche, dann könnte man schon sagen, dass da sich schon was tun könnte. Das ist das eine. Das andere ist ja auch, das wollen wir mit Rosetta dann später auch noch mal näher untersuchen, das ist einer der Punkte, auch noch mal die Frage klären, wie viel des Wassers auf der Erde ist eigentlich durch diese Kometeneinschläge gekommen. Das ist auch so eine Diskussion, die man hat. Es gibt also Wissenschaftler und sehr bekannte Kometenwissenschaftler, die sagen, dass etwa bis zu 30% des Wassers, was wir auf der Erde heute haben, dass das einfach Wasser ist, was durch die Kometen auf die Erde gebracht wurde. Und das kann man also untersuchen. Das ist so eins der Ziele, die wir mit Rosetta auch haben, um zu sehen, ob man da einen Zusammenhang bringen kann.
Kommen wir doch mal langsam auf das Rosetta-Projekt, das ja noch nicht abgeschlossen ist. Und was jetzt auch einen anderen Kometen ins Auge gefasst hat. Wann war denn klar, dass man Rosetta als Projekt starten möchte?
Da muss man zwei Daten oder ein bisschen auch wieder zurückgehen. Also Rosetta als Rosetta-Mission, wie wir sie jetzt fliegen, als eine Rendezvous-Mission mit einem Kometen, auf den man dann auch einen Länder noch absetzt. Das war erst so etwa 1993 bis 1997, in dem Zeitraum haben wir also da sehr genau studiert. Und das war eigentlich da klar, dass das unser Ziel ist. Aber die Mission, das begann eigentlich sehr viel früher. Und zwar hat ja die ESA Anfang der 80er Jahre das erste Mal geschaut, dass man ein Langfristprogramm implementieren kann, einfach um eine große Vision zu haben. Und dann auch nicht nur sozusagen in den Tag hinein lebt, sondern also längerfristig ein Programm implementiert, was große Teile des wissenschaftlichen Interesses in Europa abdecken. Und da gab es dann also dieses Szenario, dass man also Medium-Size-Missions sich herausgesucht hat. Also kleinere, mittelgroße Missionen und dann die sogenannten Cornerstones. Also sozusagen Missionen, die also wirklich wichtig waren, die sozusagen die Eckpfeiler des Programms geben sollte. Und da gab es eine Mission, die war definiert, es sollte eine Planetenmission sein. Und wenn möglich eine Mission zu einem Kometen, um auch sozusagen ein Sample, also Material aus dem Kometen zur Erde zurückzubringen, dass man das dann im Labor untersuchen kann. Das ist ja eigentlich immer das große Ziel aller Planetenmissionen. Man will erstmal sehen, wie der Planet aussieht, untersucht den, aber dann will man gerne mal was zurückbringen ins Labor, weil dann kann man die ganze Maschinerie, die man hier hat, mit der größten Auflösung, die kann man dann darauf loslassen. Oder auch Instrumente bauen, wenn man weiß, was man untersuchen möchte oder untersuchen muss. Und das war so die Idee, da war so eine Idee, das war Anfang der 80er Jahre, das war dieses Horizon 2000 Programm der ESA. Und da war das als Cornerstone sozusagen ein bisschen vordefiniert. Und jetzt gerade vor 26 Jahren, kann man sagen, am 20. Mai hat die Solar System Working Group der ESA, die hat eine Empfehlung ausgesprochen, basierend auf einem Meeting, was am Tag vorher stattgefunden hat. Und da war ich also glücklicherweise, durfte ich da mit dabei sein. Da haben wir definiert, dass wir eine Kometen, Komet Nucleus Sample Return Mission gerne hätten. Das heißt, dass die ESA mit einem Partner eine Mission definiert, dass wir zu einem Kometen fliegen können und dann eine Probe aus dem Kometen Kern nehmen, die zurück zur Erde zu bringen. Das muss man, den Termin sollte man sich genau, das war also im Mai 1985, bevor wir überhaupt Giotto gestartet hatten, haben das providente Wissenschaftler, die auch dann in der Solar System Working Group waren, die hatten sich dieses Ziel vorgenommen und das wurde auch dann von der Solar System Working Group als Empfehlung übernommen und weitergegeben in der ESA. Das war sozusagen der Auslöser. Das war aber mitgetragen durch diese ganze Euphorie, dass wir jetzt diese Giotto-Mission, das waren wir kurz vorm Start, da wussten wir, wir können die Dinge bauen. Aber das war schon klar, wir wollen schon den nächsten Schritt machen, obwohl wir noch gar keine Ergebnisse von der ersten hatten. Aber einfach, das war die Vision. Das war eigentlich der Traum auch jedes, nicht nur der Kometenwissenschaftler, sondern auch der Kosmochemiker und alles, so ein primitives Material mal im Labor zu haben. Und dann hat man also 1985 angefangen. Wir hatten dann zusammen mit den Amerikanern eine Arbeitsgruppe gebildet. Also das war ein großes, internationales Unternehmen. Das war eine ESA-NASA-Arbeitsgruppe. Und ich war als ESA-Studyscientist dabei. Und wir sollten also so eine Mission definieren, was man wissenschaftlich dann machen will, wie man auch sozusagen, welche Technologien brauchen wir noch, um so eine Mission zu machen. Und wir haben also damals angefangen. Und das ging einige Jahre. Haben wir das studiert. Und dann gab es, also nach drei Jahren, vier Jahren, war es damals schon klar, dass die Amerikaner dann nicht mitmachen konnten, weil das einfach aus programmatischen Gründen nicht in ihr Programm passte. Und dann muss man sich, wenn man die Historie ein bisschen kennt, und viele werden sich jetzt wohl das Shuttle sozusagen zu die letzten Flüge macht, vielleicht erinnern, dass damals der erste große Schlag war, dass nämlich ein Shuttle verunglückt ist. Diese Challenger-Katastrophe. Und das passierte genau an einem Morgen, als wir ein Meeting in Amerika hatten bei Caltech. Wir saßen in einem Meeting-Raum, wir haben morgens, wie in Amerika üblich, um acht Uhr angefangen. Und wir vermissten einen unserer Kollegen. Und der kam auf einmal reingestürzt und hat gesagt, der Shuttle ist explodiert. Das hat keiner glauben können. Aber für mich war das sozusagen ein kritischer Moment, wo man sagen könnte, die Mission, wie man sie geplant hat mit den Amerikanern, die Commitment to December Return, war zu ambitieus, weil die ESA alleine das nicht machen konnte. Und das war so der Auslöser, da wussten wir, da ist was passiert. Das wird also erst mal für ein paar Jahre Auswirkungen auf das Programm haben. Und das war also wirklich, das war eins der Erlebnisse, diesen zu sehen, wie meine Kollegen schockiert waren, aber wie die ganze Nation eigentlich schockiert war, dass also ein sozusagen hochtechnisch jedes Projekt, wo also jeder glaubte, da kann eigentlich nichts passieren, dass da diese Katastrophe eintritt. Und das sind dann so Punkte, wo man merkt, da passiert was und das wird Auswirkungen haben. Und da ging es dann schon los, dass es langsam war. Und dann haben wir hier in Europa überlegt, was können wir alleine machen, also unter europäischer Führerschaft. Und dann kam so die Idee, dass wir also eine, und wir haben das unter dem Schlagwort, und das bringt das zusammen, da wir keine Probe ins Labor bringen können, bringen wir das Labor zum Kometen. Also wir machen das umgekehrt, das war nicht das ganz Ideale, aber wir versuchen jetzt mal ein gutes chemisches Labor und physikalisches Labor zum Kometen zu bringen. Und das war eigentlich fast das zusammen, was wir machen sollten. Wir wollten eine Mission dann definieren, die zu einem Kometen fliegt, in eine Bahn um den Kometen geht, und dass wir da sehr, sehr gute Instrumente haben und einfach die Untersuchungen am Kometen machen. Und um da noch sozusagen das I-Tüpfelchen drauf zu setzen, war dann klar, wir wollen nicht nur rumfliegen, wenn es geht, wollen wir auch was auf den Kometen absetzen, dass wir zumindest das Material im Kometen untersuchen können, auch wenn es nur an der Oberfläche ist. Das ist sozusagen dieser Knackpunkt. Und das ist dann sozusagen, kann man sagen, 1997 wurde das dann sozusagen endgültig abgesegnet.
Dann auch natürlich mit dem Einfluss der Ergebnisse schon von Giotto.
Und da waren die Giotto-Ergebnisse schon lange mit drin. Da wurden ja die Giotto-Ergebnisse so aufregend. Und es war auch so ein großes Ereignis, dass sehr viel schon in den ersten Monaten nach dem Encounter studiert wurde und auch veröffentlicht wurde. Die Haupterkenntnisse wurden also schon sehr schnell veröffentlicht. Und schon damals war schon ganz klar, dass man die nächste Mission zum Kometen haben musste. Ja, den Wissenschaftler war das klar. Das ist natürlich eine sehr komplexe... Ich sehe mich da als Wissenschaftler da drin und man sagt das so einfach. Aber für die Wissenschaftler und für sehr viele der Wissenschaftler war es klar, dass man den nächsten Schritt machen wollte. Es ist nicht so, dass wir das unbedingt haben müssen. Da konnte man das gut begründen. Und man konnte auch viele, die nicht nur direkt auf Comedienforschung arbeiten, man muss auch sehen, dass durch diese Gelegenheit, die damals Giotto kreiert hatte, auf einmal sehr viele Wissenschaftler sich auf Comedienforschung auch gestürzt haben. Da gibt es viele Opportunisten. Wenn die Gelegenheit da ist, dann mach ich da auch was.
Aber ist natürlich auch verständlich, wenn man jetzt sieht, okay, jetzt lohnt es sich hier auch zu forschen, weil es gibt hier entsprechende Basisdaten und die waren nur darauf ausgewertet.
Ja, und da kommt es. Und wir haben da also auch sehr viele mit eingeschlossen. Das ist also nicht nur ein kleines Skription, sondern das ging quer über die Planetenforschung. Es ging zur Astronomie, weil man muss ja die Comedien beobachten. Und da ist ja viel, viel passiert jetzt die letzten Jahre. Und dann sollte man auch noch nicht vergessen, dass wir ja mit Giotto nicht 1986 aufgehört haben. Wir haben Giotto auch in den Winterschlaf versetzt. Für ein paar Jahre haben wir 1990 aufgeweckt und sind dann 1992 am zweiten Comedien vorbei geflogen. Am Comedienkriegs-Gelderup. Das war noch sozusagen eine kleine Add-on. Aber es gab ja die Giotto Extended Mission auch.
War das von Anfang an geplant?
Nein, das war nicht geplant. Also das muss man klar sagen, es war nicht geplant. Wir wussten, dass wir das machen können. Aber es war nicht geplant. Sonst hätten wir es wahrscheinlich nicht machen können, da wäre die Mission zu teuer geworden. Sondern wir haben das einfach ausprobiert.
Die Reserve war einfach nicht eingeplant?
Nein, die Reserve war nicht eingeplant. Für Giotto war ja im Hinterkopf, haben wir gesagt, der Spacecraft überlebt den Encounter nicht. Nachdem das Encounter überlebt hat, wussten wir, das war vorher schon studiert, was würde passieren, wenn Giotto am Hellischen Kometen vorbeigeflogen ist, das bleibt ja auf einer Bahn um die Sonne. Das war also schön synchronisiert mit der Erde. Wir wussten, dass es 1990 wieder nah an die Erde vorbeikommen fliegen würde. Dann haben unsere Kollegen hier, die haben dann mit allen ihren Tricks, das war der erste Gravity Assist eines Space Grafs aus dem Deep Space für die überhaupt, glaube ich. Das war also der erste Nahe-Erd-Vorbeiflug eines Space Grafs überhaupt. Da haben wir die Amerikaner geschlagen. Das also sozusagen die Erd-Gravity-Assist genommen hat, um dann seine Bahn zu ändern.
Also er hat quasi, um es nochmal klar zu machen, Giotto ist gestartet, ist quasi von der Erde weg und dann der Erde voraus dem hellischen Kometen entgegen. Und wie weit entfernt von der Sonne ist er dann auf den Kometen gestoßen?
Das war etwa in den Erdbanden. Also 1 AU war die Entfernung. Wir sind weg von der Erde, also in den Weltraum rein, aber das war nicht zu 2 AU oder zu 0,8.
Wesentlichen in der Erdbande.
Das war mehr oder weniger die Erdbahn. Also die Bahn von Giotto war ein bisschen schneller als die Erdbahn.
Und jetzt hat er sozusagen über die Zeit die Erde wieder eingeholt?
Da hat er die Erde wieder eingeholt und ist in die Nähe der Erde gekommen. Und das haben wir dann benutzt, um dann einen Earth-Gravity-Assist zu machen.
Die astronomische Schauke sozusagen?
Die astronomische Schwung zu holen, ja. Das haben wir benutzt und das war das erste Mal, dass das also gemacht wurde mit einem Spacecraft, das sozusagen aus dem tiefen Weltraum gekommen ist, das nicht in der Erdumlaufbahn war. In der Erdumlaufbahn hat man schon den Mond und all die Dinge benutzt. Da kann man also Gravity Assists machen. Aber das war das erste Spacecraft, was dann aus dem Deep Space gekommen ist und dann die Erde als Ziel genommen hat, Gravity Assists zu machen.
Aber andere Missionen haben doch auch schon die Gravitation von anderen Körpern?
Ja, aber nicht die Erde, so wie das war.
Aber ist das jetzt nur sozusagen das erste Mal war oder hat das noch eine andere Qualität?
Nein, die Qualität war, dass wir dann die Freiheit hatten, uns einen anderen Komet noch herauszusuchen.
Und welcher war das?
Das war dann Griggs Gelarup. Wie häufig kommt der so rum? Er kommt auch alle 5,5, 6 Jahre rum. Sagen wir mal, knapp 6 Jahre.
Alle 6 Jahre?
Alle 6 Jahre.
Also ein häufiger Gast.
Das ist ein einfacheres Ziel. War das dann so Zufall? Das ist das, was die Leute auch sehen sollten. Tschurjumow-Gerasimenko gehört zu derselben Klasse. Das sind alles Kometen, die irgendwann mal durch den Jupiter gestört wurden. Die haben alle so eine Umlaufperiode von 6 Jahren. Also plus, minus ein bisschen. Paar Monate. Das sind die Kometen, die für uns erfassbar sind. Wir gehen nicht zu sehr exotischen Kometen mit exotischen Bahnen. Sondern wenn man richtig guckt, sind das alles Kometen, die irgendwann mal sozusagen über den Jupiter eingefangen wurden und dann auf so eine Bahn sind, die sich dann so mit einer Periode von 6 Jahren bewegt. Das sind eigentlich alles die Kometen, die für uns zurzeit technisch zugänglich sind mit unseren Raumfahrzeugen. Also auch die Kometen, die hinterher von der NASA untersucht wurden. Die sind alle so mit Umlaufzeiten in der Größenordnung.
Wie musste man denn jetzt... Also Giotto kam dann nochmal an der Erde vorbei, hat sich Schwung geholt. Wohin musste dann dieser Schwung gehen? Also war das dann immer noch viel? Also war auch der nächste Kometentreff ein Treff in der Erdlaufbahn?
Der war in der Nähe der Erdumlaufbahn. Also von der Sonne, wenn man die Sonnenentfernung nimmt, das war in der Nähe. Wir haben die Bahn nicht so stark geändert, sondern einfach, dass wir hier wieder ein schneller Vorbeiflug am Kriegs-Geller-Rub. Und das war auch in der Nähe der Erdbahn. Weil Giotto wäre auch wieder in der Nähe der Erdbahn zurückgekommen. Und zwar 1994, 1995, ist wahrscheinlich auch wieder ziemlich nah an der Erde vorbeigeflogen. Weil einige unserer Wissenschaftler hatten dann Appetit gehabt und haben gemeint, wir könnten nochmal so was tun. Aber die Kamera hatte jetzt nicht so einen Schaden genommen, dass sie nicht mehr benutzt war. Giotto haben wir im Winter schlafen versetzt, haben es 1990 aufgeweckt im Sommer, um einfach zu testen, welche Instrumente noch funktioniert haben. Und da hat sich rausgestellt, dass die Kamera nicht mehr benutzt war.
Aber das war ja nicht das einzige.
Das war nicht das einzige Instrument. Wir hatten also noch so ein Fotopolarimeter. Das Staub-Experiment hat noch funktioniert. Das Plasma-Experiment, das war dann die Hauptsache, dass das Plasma-Experiment noch funktioniert hatte. Und dann wurde die Entscheidung gefällt, dass es für die geringen Kosten, die das jetzt zusätzlich erfordert hätte, dass es doch nochmal vertretbar war, 1992 am Kriegskellerup noch schnell vorbei zu fliegen. Da sind wir auch näher vorbeigeflogen, 200 Kilometer etwa Abstand. Das konnten wir natürlich nicht so genau feststellen, weil wir keine Kamera mehr hatten. Aber wir haben das so indirekt über die Instrumente raus. Es war also ein sehr nahe Vorbeiflug, 200 Kilometer. Und danach haben wir gesagt, Giotto hat seine Pflichten alle übererfüllt. Und jetzt lassen wir es in Frieden weiterfliegen, in Ruhe. Weil das ist das eine. Das zweite war, wir hätten vielleicht noch mal versuchen können, das Einschuss zu halten. Aber man muss sehen, mit der Technologie, die wir hatten, also die Computer, es ist schon ein ziemlicher Aufwand, Computer über sechs Jahre oder acht Jahre, mit derselben Hardware zu arbeiten. Weil die wird ja auch veraltet.
Das ist ja schon auf der Erde selbst ein Problem.
Das war auch hier auf der Erde. Das war mehr das Problem hier auf der Erde als bei Giotto. Weil wir mussten damals die ganzen Computer, die wir hatten in 1986, die haben wir eingemottet, dass wir sie 92 nochmal benutzen konnten. Viele von unseren Experimentatoren haben ihre Software umschreiben müssen, weil einfach diese alten Computer-Motelle, ich hab das schon fast vergessen, da gab es so, was gab es da, Commodore 86 war glaube ich, Commodore und Atari oder wie sie hießen, also alle Dinge. Und für Experten war das wie ein Museum. Als dann 92 kamen einige noch mit den alten Dingern an. Das war also wie ein Computermuseum, während andere natürlich ihre Software ein bisschen umgeschrieben hatten. Aber das zeigte, welcher Fortschritt sozusagen in der Zeit gemacht war. Aber das war für uns, was wichtig ist, für Operations ist, da müssen sie sehr hohe Anforderungen stellen. Und da kommt es auch darauf an, dass sie also die Computer-Hardware entweder noch haben und die über 10 Jahre zu benutzen oder einzumodden wieder ranzubringen. Das ist schon ein bisschen Aufwand.
Kommen wir mal auf Rosetta. Das ist ja auch die Mission, die jetzt gerade unmittelbar davor ist, genau wieder in so einen Winterschlaf gebracht zu werden. Das Ziel ist also, einen anderen Kometen zu erwischen, und zwar mit diesem unausprechlichen Namen Tschurjumow-Gerasimenko. Das war ja aber nicht das erste Ziel eigentlich.
Nein, das erste Ziel war der Komet Wirtannen. Also das Wirtannen ist ein finnischer Wissenschaftler gewesen, der den Kometen entdeckt hat, Tschurjumow-Gerasimenko.
Das scheint so eine goldene Regel zu sein, dass Kometen nur von Wissenschaftlern mit unausprechlichen Namen.
Nein, Halley ist doch ganz einfach, Wild ist auch ganz einfach, Tempel.
Aber da fliegt man nicht hin.
Da fliegt man nicht hin. Man muss auch sagen, so Kometen, die um 1900 entdeckt wurden, da waren unsere lieben Kollegen nicht sehr weit von hier in Heidelberg, da waren sie sehr aktiv. Und die haben auch ein paar Namen, da hat man ein paar gute deutsche Namen für die Kometen, also Enke, wenn man so ein paar bekannte nimmt. Das sind mehr deutsche Namen, das hängt auch davon ab, einfach von den Beobachtern und wer natürlich die besten Instrumente hatte. Und man muss inzwischen sehen, dass es also für einen professionellen Astronom ist, Kometen-Untersuchungen, da macht man Spektroskopie, aber die sind nicht auf der Jagd nach neuen Kometen. Das wird viel von Amateuren gemacht inzwischen. Also wir hatten ursprünglich, wollten wir zum Kometenwirt an, weil unser ursprüngliches Startdatum für die Mission war im Frühjahr 2003 und leider ist im Dezember 2002 ein Arianeflug mit neuen Hardware, mit einem neuen Triebwerk, der ist leider gescheitert. Das heißt, das musste erst untersucht werden und nach diesem Unfall sozusagen, wurden die Ariane, die Raketen, erst einmal am Boden gehalten, um diese Unfallursache zu untersuchen. Und da wir natürlich sehr abhängig sind von unserem Szenario im Weltraum, wir brauchen ja diese Vorbeiflüge, ist eine Stadtverzögerung von ein paar Monaten. Dann passt unser ganzes Szenario nicht mehr. Wir müssen ja zum richtigen Zeitpunkt am Mars oder an der Venus, wo immer auch sein, oder an der Erde wieder zurück. Und da war es schon klar, dass wir wussten auch nicht, wie schnell die Ariane sozusagen wieder den Betrieb aufnehmen würde. Und dann haben wir also sehr, sehr schnell geguckt, welches Ziel lag denn nun in der Reichweite und wann müssen wir starten. Und haben also sozusagen das ganze Szenario für die Mission sehr schnell angepasst. Und wir kamen dann also auf Tschurjumow-Gerasimenko und dann mit einem Startdatum ein Jahr später, also im März 2004. Und wir sind ja endlich am 2. März 2004 gestartet. Also ein sehr schönes Datum, 2, 3, 4. Und das kann man sich gut merken. Und das war die erste Hürde. Und da kann man sich vorstellen, dass es uns ziemlich nerven gekostet hat dieses Jahr, um das alles sehr schnell umzuändern.
Also das Ding ist jetzt schon seit 7 Jahren unterwegs.
Genau 7 Jahre.
Und hat eigentlich noch nicht viel gesehen.
Das kann man nicht so sagen. Wir haben schon viele Tests gemacht. Wir haben also auch schon einiges gesehen. Wir sind ja an der Erde dreimal vorbeigeflogen. Aber wir haben also einen sehr schönen Vorbeiflug am Mars gehabt. In etwa 200 Kilometer über der Mars-Oberfläche haben wir auch sehr schöne Aufnahmen gemacht. Ein bisschen gesehen hat es Rosetta schon. Allerdings noch nicht so etwas ganz Aufregendes, sagen wir mal so. Ich meine, Mars war schon aufregend, einfach zu zeigen, was wir machen können. Wir haben aber die Zeit auch gut genutzt, um unsere Instrumente wirklich auszutesten. Und durch diese ganze Hektik vor den Staats war das doch eine Zeit, die wir gebraucht haben, um jetzt alle Instrumente soweit zu kriegen, dass wir dann für den Kometen und für die Hauptphase der Mission dann auch fertig sind und vorbereitet.
Man muss da am Mars vorbei. Wir haben ja in der Folge zur Missionsplanung auch schon ausführlich über diese eigentliche Planung von solchen Traktionsrouten gesprochen. Da war Rosetta ja auch ein Thema, weil das ja ein sehr aufwendiger Flug ist. Man muss halt zum Mars, man muss wieder an der Erde vorbei, insgesamt dreimal, um einfach einerseits die richtigen Speed zu bekommen, aber auch die richtige Richtung zu bekommen. Genau. Weil diesmal muss man ja nun wirklich hinterherfliegen.
Wir müssen hinterherfliegen, wir müssen gucken, dass wir sozusagen alle Energie kriegen, dass wir wirklich mit dem Kometen dann mitfliegen können. Das muss ziemlich präzise sein. Wir wollen ja nicht unseren Treibstoff dafür benutzen, um noch ein bisschen schneller zu werden oder abzubremsen, all die Dinge, weil wir haben nicht so viel Treibstoff dabei. Das muss also alles sehr, sehr genau gemacht werden.
Aber das heißt ja, dass man im Prinzip voll im Sandstrahl dieses Komentens dann landet.
Ja, aber da muss man jetzt aufpassen. Das ist der Vorteil dieser Rendezvous-Mission, dass man eine sehr kleine Relativgeschwindigkeit hat. Bei Halley sind wir mit 68 km pro Sekunde vorbeigeflogen. Die anderen Missionen, die jetzt bei den Komenten vorbeigeflogen sind, die sind in der Größenordnung von 10 km vorbeigeflogen, immer noch rasend schnell. Wir fliegen vorbei, dann ist die Relativgeschwindigkeit ein halber Meter. Wir fliegen ja mit dem Komenten mit. Dann ist der Staub auf einmal, die Gefahr durch den Staub, minimiert. Diese gefährlichen Vorbeiflüge hatten wir ja bei den Asteroiden. Da sind wir schnell vorbeigeflogen. Wir hatten ja zwei Asteroiden und das sind schon interessante Ziele. Das war so am Weg, dass wir wirklich gute Wissenschaft machen konnten. Aber wenn man zum Komenten kommt, das ist der Vorteil der Rendezvous Mission. Wir fliegen mit dem Komenten mit. Der Staub kommt mit Gas mit 1 km pro Sekunde vom Komenten weg. Der Staub ist dann auch der ganz kleine, etwa maximal mit der Geschwindigkeit. Aber der ist ungefährlich.
Kilometer pro Sekunde ist ja jetzt nicht langsam.
Das sind ganz kleine Staubteilchen. Die anderen kommen in der Größenordnung maximal von 200 m pro Sekunde. Selbst die sind noch nicht sehr groß. Die ganz großen kommen ganz langsam aus.
Also ist man sich sicher, dass man das Gerät stabil gebaut hat?
Nein, da sind wir sicher, dass das Gerät stabil gebaut ist. Wir haben auch untersucht, was da passiert, wenn so Staub kommt. Auf einer Glasplatte werden Sie da überhaupt nichts sehen. Wir haben also auch Versuche dazu gemacht. Das größere Problem, was wir haben mit dieser Staubgeschwindigkeit, wir haben ja auch zwei Instrumente an Bord, die den Staub sammeln wollen und dann im Instrument untersuchen, da muss man erst mal gucken, dass die genug Staub sammeln können. Weil wenn der Staub so mit 50 m pro Sekunde oder 200 m pro Sekunde kommt, da ist nicht klar, dass der also klebt auf der Sammelfläche, sondern da muss man also schon spezielle Sammelfläche haben, dass der Staub da oben drauf sitzen bleibt. Und das ist auch unsere größere, wenn man von der Gefahr sprechen wollte, ist, was man also jeder sieht, wenn er nicht staubwischt, dass sich mit der Zeit eine Staubschicht auf dem Tisch oder auf dem Schrank sozusagen aufbaut. Und da könnte man sagen, wenn das also ein bisschen, da muss man aufpassen, ob nicht irgendwann mal alles mit Staub bedeckt ist, dass zum Beispiel die optischen Oberflächen dann ein bisschen, naja, Scheibenwischer gibt es nicht, aber wir wissen auch, dass sich der Staub nicht so da drauf niederlegen wird.
Wenn man jetzt so hinterher fliegt, das heißt, man hat ja nicht dieselbe Geschwindigkeit, sondern man will sich ihm ja permanent nähern. Wie weit entfernt von der Erde findet dieses Rendezvous statt?
Das Rendezvous findet etwa 3,5 AU von der Erde ab. Also wenn man das jetzt in Kilometer umrechnet, sind das, sagen wir mal, 500 Millionen Kilometer.
Da hat man ja schon, sagen wir mal, jetzt keine Echtzeitsteuerung mehr. Man kann jetzt nicht so sofort reagieren.
Das ist eins der Probleme, dass wir haben. Also Probleme, das wissen wir, dass wir da aufpassen müssen. Weil jedes AU, also jede Distanz von der Erde zur Sonne sind etwa acht Minuten. Da kann man sich dann ganz einfach merken. Also wenn wir jetzt da sind, dann haben wir schon mal so etwa eine halbe Stunde braucht das Signal, bis es dort ist. Und es braucht ja wieder eine halbe Stunde, bis wir wissen, was passiert ist an Bord. Muss ja wieder zurückkommen. Und darum müssen viele dieser Dinge automatisch ablaufen. Also wir überlegen uns das, was da passiert. Das wird alles vorprogrammiert. Dann werden die Kommandos zum Spacecraft geschickt. Und das muss dann mehr oder weniger autonom. Es führt die Befehle aus. Und wir warten dann ab, was passiert ist. Aber es ist nicht so, dass man mit einem Joystick da sitzt, wie man so ein Computerspiel macht. Diese Zeit merkt man. Wenn man hier sitzt, dann weiß man ja, vor einer halben Stunde ist was passiert.
Das heißt, eigentlich muss das alles weitgehend automatisiert werden?
Das ist weitgehend automatisiert. Und vorgeplant.
Nimmt dann Rosetta den Kometen ins Visier? Ist das so ein optisches Tracking zu dem Zeitpunkt? Oder meint man einfach nur zu wissen, wo man ist und fliegt einfach in diese Richtung?
Wir könnten diese Navigation machen. Dass wir also so ein gekoppeltes System haben, wo man also die Navigationskamera, den Kometen, im Visier hat. Aber das ist für dieses Szenario, das haben wir gemacht, für die Asteroiden-Vorbeiflüge. Das war dann schön, dass alles ausrichtet. Das werden wir da nicht machen. Da haben wir trotzdem genug Zeit. Wir werden uns also so langsam an den Kometen anschleichen. Wir wissen jetzt ungefähr, in welcher Entfernung wir das Rosetta setzen, das Spacecraft. Und werden dann erstmal den Komet beobachten von dort. Dann senden wir die Bilder auf die Erde. Dann können wir also genau optimieren, in welche Richtung wir da ranfliegen. Und dann werden wir Rosetta erstmal in einen Umlauf, also sobald wir wissen, wie der Komet aussieht, und die ersten Informationen haben, wo er genau ist, dass wir also relativ die Entfernung auch bestimmen können. Dann gehen wir also in eine Bahn, die ziemlich verhältnismäßig weit vom Kometen ist. Und machen da also unsere Messungen. Und dann bringen wir den Rosetta in eine nähere... Und beim Kometen, da der eine geringe Dichte hat, da muss man nicht unbedingt an eine Bahn gehen, sondern dann kann man schöne Figuren um den Kometen herumfliegen. Es ist nicht eine Umlaufbahn wie ein Air-Satellit, sondern man kann also Bahnen auswählen. Wir müssen ja erstmal alle Messungen machen. Wir kennen von unserem Kometen zwar schon sehr viel, weil wir ein sehr großes, ausgebreitetes Bodenbeobachtungsprogramm mit dem besten Teleskopen haben, die es auf der Erde gibt, also unsere Kollegen vom European Southern Observatory. Die sind da also sehr stark involviert, also mit Wissenschaftlern, die bei Rosetta auch stark beteiligt sind. Die haben da Beobachtungsprogramme. Aber wir müssen noch genau herausfinden mit hoher Präzision, wie schnell der Kometenkern rotiert, wie seine Rotationsachse steht, dass wir dann also genau wissen, was passiert da. Und dann sozusagen unsere Bahn und auch die ganzen Aktivitäten, die wir machen können, die müssen ja sozusagen gekoppelt werden an die Rotation des Kometen. Weil wir wollen ja, wenn wir was beobachten, müssen wir genau wissen, wann kommt sozusagen der Punkt, wann können wir den sehen.
Wie lange wird diese Beobachtungsphase dann voraussichtlich dauern?
Also wir haben die genaue Beobachtungsphase, also das sind ein paar Monate, aber wir haben also auch, weil wir den Länder ja absetzen müssen, jetzt kommt ja unser großer Freund von der DLR, die haben ja sehr viel investiert, zusammen mit dem Max-Bank-Institut in Lindau, Kettenburg, um so einen Länder zu bauen. Die kommen jetzt ins Spiel, weil wenn wir den Länder absetzen wollen, wollen wir ja genau wissen, wo wir denn hinsetzen. Und da haben wir also so eine Phase von etwa drei Wochen eingerechnet, dass wir also sehr genau den Kometenkern kartieren, dass wir dann also aussuchen können, auf welchem Punkt wollen wir denn den Länder setzen.
Also schon bevor dieser Länder abgesetzt ist, wird das wahrscheinlich der bestkartierte Komet aller Zeiten sein.
Sicher, müssen wir haben. Das wird der einzige Komet sein, der wirklich gut kartiert ist.
Ja, und das heißt, man kennt exakt genau die Oberfläche, man wird sehr hochauflösende Bilder davon haben.
Da gehen wir so in die Größenordnung 10 cm, also schon sehr, sehr genau.
Das wird sicherlich sehr interessant.
Das wird interessant und ich glaube, da wird also einiges an Diskussion hier in Darmstadt sein. Wir werden also die Teams zusammenbringen, weil sozusagen die Auswahl des Landeplatzes, wir haben Kriterien dafür, aber man muss ja erst mal den Kometen sehen, dass man wirklich weiß, was siehst du da oder was siehst du nicht. Und wo willst du jetzt den Länder hinsetzen? Da wird es wahrscheinlich auch schon mal ein paar wissenschaftliche Diskussionen geben, ein paar ganz heftige, wie wir es so die Leute kennen, die alle beteiligt sind, weil der eine will das, der andere das. Und das Zweite ist natürlich, dass unsere Kollegen hier von ESOC, von der Flugdynamik, die ja das ganze Szenario dann implementieren müssen, die müssen ja auch noch sagen, ob das möglich ist. Weil der Länder ist ja passiv. Wir sind ja im Orbit und dann kriegt er einen kleinen Push, also wird rausgestoßen mit 30 cm pro Sekunde und dann sprichwörtlich fällt er runter auf den Komenten.
Das heißt, er hat keine eigenen Treibwerke?
Der hat keine Lageregeln, der hat nur ein Triebwerk, was ihn nach unten sozusagen auf den Kometen draufdrückt, dass er dann nicht...
Auf welchem Abstand soll der dann losgeschickt werden?
Also das wissen wir noch nicht so genau, aber um die Flugzeit sehr kurz zu halten, weil das bringt ja Fehler, weil wollen wir doch gucken, dass das so etwa ein paar Kilometer, ich sag mal ganz grob, vielleicht vier, fünf Kilometer, wenn es geht. Das dauert noch ein bisschen. Ja, das ist, wenn man dann so runterfährt, dass der also nur mit einem halben Meter pro Sekunde, oder mit einem Meter pro Sekunde, wenn sie dann, sagen wir mal, vier Kilometer nehmen, dann haben sie 4000 Sekunden. Das ist schon eine schöne Zeit. Aber das wollen wir natürlich kürzer machen.
Aber der Komet ist ja eigentlich ein enorm, für astronomische Verhältnisse, enorm kleines Objekt. Der hat ja auch kaum Anziehungskraft.
Das ist ein Staub, ja, der hat sehr geringe Anziehungskraft. Das wissen wir nicht, vielleicht ist er auch lang. Wenn man das letzte Bild gesehen hat, es gibt auch so ein bisschen lang gestreckte Dinge. Je nachdem, was man so hat, man hat ja alle Formen. Aber das ist definitiv keine Kugel. Das ist ein irreguläres Objekt. Das wissen wir auch, dass er irregulär ist. Aber das werden wir dann erst mal sehen, wenn wir dort sind. Wir müssen sehen, wie er rotiert. Wir müssen sehen, wie die Oberfläche aussieht. Ich meine, der Länder, wenn sie sich den mal angeguckt haben, das ist vielleicht ein Meter Durchmesser. Und sie müssen natürlich gucken, den wollen sie nicht irgendwo landen lassen.
Der Komet ist ungefähr so 3 Kilometer.
Ja, 4 Kilometer im Durchmesser.
Der passt da schon drauf.
Der passt auf jeden Fall drauf. Sie sagen das so, man sagt dann 4 Kilometer, das ist doch gar nichts. Der Hellesche Komet ist ja so etwa 16 Kilometer lang. Wir hatten also viele Meetings mit unseren Italienern auf Capri, auf der Insel. Capri von Ende zu Ende ist etwa so die Dimension, so 16 Kilometer. Man muss sich das einfach mal vorstellen. Man sitzt auf einem Kometen. Man kann sich das vorstellen, dann sagt man, da musst du jetzt einen Meter so ein Ding runterbringen. Dann denkt man, das Ding ist so riesig groß. Das ist genau, wenn sie vor einer Felswand stehen, die also 4 Kilometer hoch ist. Diese Dimension muss man sich ein bisschen im Kopf reinbringen. Dieser ein Meter, das ist so ein kleines Pünktchen, was da runter muss. Aber wir müssen natürlich gucken, dass die Oberfläche vielleicht auch ziemlich glatt ist. Weil sie wollen nicht irgendwo hin, wo so kleine Erhebungen, die so ein Meter sind, dass das Ding rumkippt. Das ist sehr flexibel gebaut. Da haben unsere lieben Kollegen schon viel Gehirnschmal, kann man mal so salopp sagen, reingebracht, damit es auch mal auf eine geneigte Fläche landen kann. Aber das will man natürlich rausholen. Man will einen interessanten Platz finden, wo man das hinsetzen kann. Plus, man muss ja auch darüber denken, dass, wenn das da mal auf dem Kometen sitzt, wir wollen ja auch mit dem Orbiter kommunizieren, weil die Daten gehen ja vom Länder zum Orbiter, also zum Rosetta Space Graph, was um den Kometen herumfliegt und erst von da runter zur Erde. Und dann muss man natürlich gucken, dass der liebe Länder nicht irgendwo sitzt im Schatten und wir können keinen Kontakt mit ihm halten. Das spielt alles mit, wie oft kann man dann kommunizieren, wie oft sieht man den Länder. Wir haben ja auch ein Instrument drauf, was also auf dem Orbiter sitzt und auf dem Länder, das sozusagen die innere Struktur des Kometenkerns studieren will, des Konzertinstruments wie so eine Tomographie, die wir jetzt auch schon gesagt haben. Die müssen ja sozusagen Kontakt haben, dass man die also in der richtigen Orbit hat, dass die also ihre Messungen machen kann. Das sind also so Einschränkungen, die man dann alle mit in der Wege ziehen kann. Es ist nicht einfach, dass wir das Ding runterwerfen wollen.
Aber wie verhindert man denn, die Gravitation von diesem Objekt ist ja sehr gering.
Die müssen wir aber erst noch mal genau feststellen.
Kann es ja nicht sein, dass man diesen Länder da hinwirft und dann prallt er irgendwie ab?
Das ist eine der Gefahren, die wir haben. Aber dafür haben wir beim Länderweg, habe ich es erwähnt, ein Triebwerk auf dem Länder, was den Länder sozusagen auf die Oberfläche draufdrückt. Er hat doch ein Triebwerk. Er hat ein Triebwerk, aber keine Lagerregung. Es ist also nur eine Düse, was ihn runterdrückt. Und dann sind in den Füßen des Länders, er hat ja drei Füße, sind noch mal sozusagen wie Schrauben drin, die ihn eigentlich fest ankern können auf dem Kometen. Plus er hat zwei Harpunen. Und sobald die Füße sozusagen die Oberfläche berühren, werden die Harpunen gezündet und dann gehen so zwei Harpunen in den Länders.
Was ist denn die Erwartung, wie weich diese Oberfläche ist?
Das ist die große Frage, das wissen wir nicht so genau. Ich nehme an, also es gibt so Theorien, die sagen, dass es also wie so ganz oben auf der Oberfläche vielleicht fast wie so lockerer Staub sein könnte. Also ich meine, dass die Oberfläche, das ist meine persönliche Meinung, so mehr in der Richtung geht. Das kommt also sehr nahe, wenn sie Schnee am Straßenrand haben, in ganz kalter Winter. Und sie gehen auf den Straßenrand, der auch viel befahren ist, und dann wird der Schnee verdreckt. Und der Schnee schmilzt ja nicht, der sublimiert einfach weg, aber der wird nach einer gewissen Zeit ziemlich hart. Und ich denke, dass wir so in der Richtung kommen, dass die Oberfläche doch ziemlich hart ist. Weil das ist also wie das Eis sublimiert an der Oberfläche weg und da bauen sich Bindungen auf. Und der Komet ist ja furchtbar alt. Und wir haben mit Fachleuten gesprochen, die meinen, dass er zwar geringe Dichte hat, wir gehen davon aus, dass er nur 0,3 Gramm pro Kubikzentimeter Dichte hat. Also es ist wie ein lockerer Schwamm. Also es kommt fast so wie an den Schnee, den wir hier haben. Oder vielleicht noch weniger. Aber dass diese Bindungen zwischen den einzelnen Schneekristallen und wenn es... Ich sage jetzt Kristalle, das sind keine Kristalle da, weil das eine Form von Schnee ist, die wir so gar nicht kennen hier auf der Erde. Aber dass die Bindungen sehr hart sind. Man kann da also schon draufstehen. Also ich bin der Meinung, der Länder wird nicht einsinken. Es gab ja auch immer Leute, die machen das scherzhaft, weil das die Leute ein bisschen aufregt. Die sagen dann, was passiert in den Ländern? Geht dann und dann sinkt er da in dem Pulverschnee ein. Also so Dinge...
Steckt dann einfach mitten im Kometen.
Ja genau, so Dinge gibt es auch. Ich sage dann immer noch, dann lernen wir auch viel, wenn wir wissen, der verschwindet da.
Was ist die Erwartung? Was weiß man über die Gesamtzusammensetzung? Wie groß ist der Wasseranteil von so einem?
Das ist die große Frage. Wie groß der Wasseranteil ist und der Staubanteil. Das war eine Sache, die auch bei Giotto rausgekommen ist. Wir haben immer davon ausgegangen, dass es ein schmutziger Schneeball ist. Das ist ja das, was man für einen Komet sagt, wenn man das erklären will. Das ist ein schmutziger Schneeball. Da ist Eis und Staub drin. Oder gefrorene Gase und Staub drin. Uwe Keller, der PI, der Kamera von Giotto, hat mit seinem Team den Begriff gegeben, dass es wahrscheinlich mehr ein gefrorener Matschball ist. Dass da mehr Dreck ist und das ist dann gefroren. Aber der Anteil von Wasser, also wenn man H2O, was man gemessen hat, hat, der müsste zumindest von den Molekülen her, von den Teilchen, fast 80% von dem, was da rausgeht, Gas. Aber der Massenanteil, es ist wahrscheinlich so, dass der mehr Dreck ist, also vom Gewicht her. Viel mehr Dreck, aber wir wissen, dass das Ganze keine feste Struktur ist. Matschball kann man sich nicht vorstellen, dass das ein hartes Gebilde ist. Ich habe ja gesagt, die Dichte ist sehr gering, also 0,3, das ist ein lockerer Schwamm. Dass da, wenn man so anguckt, ist doch vom Gewicht her oder von der Masse her mehr Staub drin ist, als sozusagen gefrorenes Gas. Aber das spekuliert sie jetzt.
Ich meine, diese Komet in der Halley, ich weiß nicht, wie nah kommt der der Sonne in seiner Urlauffbahn?
Ja, so knapp 1 AU.
Also auch nicht näher als die Erde?
Ein bisschen näher als die Erde.
Ich dachte, das wäre noch ein bisschen näher. Aber wenn so ein Komet so auf Merkur-Abstand zur Sonne gehen würde, würde wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viel von ihm beruhigt bleiben.
Die sind ja sehr groß. Ich meine, die supplimieren ja. Und das ist sozusagen wie so ein Temperatur-Buffer. Weil dann geht die Energie in die Supplamation rein. Das heißt, die Temperatur geht nicht sehr viel runter. Der verliert zwar mehr von seinem Material an der Oberfläche, aber es ist nicht so, dass die Temperatur auf einmal riesig hochgeht. Es ist auch so, wenn sie ihren Champagner in Eis setzen, in Eiswasser, das Wasser bleibt sehr lange kühl bei einer Temperatur. Und ziemlich konstant, weil die Energie dann sozusagen da rein geht, das Eis zu schmelzen. Und das bleibt also ziemlich... Und das muss man auch sagen, dass die Oberflächentemperatur von dem Ding, das bleibt bei 200 Kelvin oder so was, oder 220 Kelvin. Und da muss man sehen, wie viel Material da abgeht. Der überlebt eine gewisse Zeit. Aber wir haben die Komenten, die ganz nah an die Sonne kommen. Wenn die lang genug da, oder wenn sie zu dicht rankommen, die gehen natürlich in einem... Die sind in einem Nu weg. Aber wir sehen sehr viele Komenten, die wir... So hoh unser Sonnen-Spacecraft war, der sehr viele Komenten beobachtet, die da einfach ins Field of View reinkommen. Und die überleben das schon mal da vorbei. Also das ist... Das dauert schon lange. Und ich meine, bis zu vier Kilometer, also diese Radius, da müssen sie eine Schicht... einige Schichten da oben weg haben. Und der ist ja nicht so lange in der Sonne, weil das ist ja die schnellste Phase der Bahn. Also da spielt sowas mit. Also das ist nicht, dass der dann gleich verschwindet. Da gehen halt statt zwei Meter, gehen vielleicht mal drei Meter weg.
Offensichtlich, dass die nicht so schnell verschwinden, weil sie kommen ja beständig immer wieder und kämmen ja zurück.
Ich hab das untersucht früher mit dem Staub. Der ist genau selbe. Der Staub spiralt auch rein zur Sonne. Und da muss man also wirklich aufpassen, was passiert. Ob der lange genug aufgeheizt wird, der Staub, da gibt es also auch ganz wunderbare Effekte. Der überlebt das auch länger, als man denkt. Weil einfach sich die Temperatur stabilisiert. Und dann kommen dann auch andere Effekte dazu. Also da ist schon, außer wenn der Helle bis etwa zur Venusbahn käme oder kommt, muss ich jetzt ehrlich sagen, das hab ich auch nicht alles so parat im Kopf, der überlebt das hier lange. Das ist kein Problem.
Jetzt die Idee, das Labor zum Kometen zu tragen. Das Labor ist ja vor allem dieser Länder.
Nein, der Länder ist eins, der Labor. Also da muss man schon ein bisschen Unterschied machen. Also der Länder hat sehr viele, sehr hochkomplizierte Instrumente an Bord. Das ist eins der Labor, dass der Länder den Kometen direkt untersucht, an der Oberfläche und ein bisschen unter die Oberfläche noch so guckt. Und dann haben wir natürlich auch sehr ähnliche Instrumente, ein bisschen größer, vielleicht noch ein bisschen komplizierter, auch an Bord von Rosetta, die ja dann sozusagen die Koma, auch in der Nähe des Kometen. Wir kommen ja bis auf vielleicht bis 5 Kilometer, da gehen wir ja ran und können dann also auch sehr, sehr viel messen. Also wir haben einen Atomic Force Mikroskop an Bord, was also mit Nanometerauflösungen, also die Staubteilchen angucken kann. Wir haben ein Instrument an Bord, das die Staubteilchen selbst untersucht, die Zusammensetzung. Und wir haben ein Instrument, was also zwei große Sensoren sind, die also die Zusammensetzung der Moleküle des Gases untersuchen. Und so ähnliche Instrumente für die Gasuntersuchung haben wir auch auf dem Länder. Und der Länder hat ja sozusagen, er muss ja, um sozusagen ein Hauptziel zu verfolgen, sagen wir ja, der Länder muss eigentlich nur eine Woche funktionieren. Dann hat er schon einen größten Teil der Wissenschaft gemacht. Und wir gehen aber davon aus, dass das natürlich oder hoffentlich noch viel länger funktioniert. Aber die spielen zusammen. Also das ist nicht so, dass man sagt, der Länder ist die Hauptsache. Ich meine, für uns ist der Orbiter die Hauptsache, aber der Länder ist ein wichtiger Teil.
Ich habe mir jetzt nur so ein bisschen von dieser Aussage, man will ja mal das Zeug mal so richtig in der Hand haben.
Ja, genau.
Das sind Interpretationen.
Jaja, da haben sie recht, in der Hand haben, weil beim Länder haben wir einen Bohrer, der geht da rein, holt das Material und dann füttert dieser Bohrer mit der Verteiler und dann füttert das in die Instrumente. Das ist genau, was sie sagen. Da haben wir das Material in der Hand, in unserer künstlichen. Während die anderen sammeln das so ein bisschen und untersuchen uns gleich.
Für Rosetta ist aber dann auf jeden Fall mit diesem erreichen, dieses Kometen, ist das auf jeden Fall die Endstation. Also der wird dann nicht, aber im Idealfall kann er jetzt ein permanenter Begleiter bleiben. Ist das vorstellbar?
Das ist, na im Ideal, sagen wir so, die Natur wird ihn als permanenten Begleiter da ranlassen. Wir werden ihn wahrscheinlich nicht mehr verfolgen können. Wir können also keine Information mehr von Rosetta kriegen, ab einer bestimmten Zeit. Also der bleibt, die Natur, man schafft es, weil er ist auf der Bahn mit dem Kometen und der wird dann für, ich sag schon fast, immer und ewig, irgendwie mit dem Kometen mitfliegen. Wir werden ein bisschen auseinanderdriften, aber das ist wie so ein großer Staubbrocken, der vom Kometen. Aber wir haben, erstens können wir die Lageregelung, wir haben nicht mehr genug Treibstoff an Bord, nach einer gewissen Zeit, dass wir also einfach sozusagen die Lageregelung so machen können, dass wir wirklich nahe bei bleiben. Das andere ist, wir haben ja Solar Arrays, also die Sonnenpaneele, und die Energie kommt ja aus den Sonnenpaneele und wir werden nach, sozusagen wir bleiben ja mit dem Kometen durch seinen sonnennexten Punkt und gehen dann wieder raus. Und irgendwann müssten wir sozusagen dann auch Rosetta wieder in Hibernation tun, weil wir entfernen uns ja wieder von der Sonne, wie wir es jetzt auch machen.
Also Hibernation ist dieses Herunterfahren des gesamten Systems, um Energie zu sparen.
Und das müssten wir dann auch wieder machen und dann müssten wir auf gut Glück hoffen, dass wir ihn wieder aufwecken können. Also theoretisch ist das möglich.
Aber man hat noch keine konkrete Erwartungshaltung, dass das klappen könnte.
Wir haben das auch noch nicht, also da kann ich auch aus tiefem Herzen das sozusagen sagen. Also wir haben das auch nicht so vorbereitet. Wir glauben, dass wir die Mission, ich sag mal so ganz salopp, das alles auslutschen an Möglichkeiten, die wir haben und dann abschalten werden. Aber theoretisch, und das ist ganz klar, das ist nicht nur theoretisch, das ist die Natur, das ist die Himmelsmaschanik. Rosetta wird auf einer Bahn wie der Tschurjumow-Gerasimenko um die Sonne rumfliegen und das für ewige Zeit. Und er wird nicht ganz nah dran bleiben, weil da gibt es natürlich Effekte, die auf der Spacecraft ein bisschen wegdriften. Aber in kosmischen Dimensionen bleibt er ziemlich nah dran.
Was ist so die Bahn von dem Kometen? Wo dreht er sich normalerweise so herum?
Naja, ich mein, der geht ja, das Perihelion ist nicht ganz bei 1 AU, der ist bei 1,2 AU jetzt, das hat sich immer über die Zeit noch geändert. Der nächste Punkt ist 1,2 AU und der geht also bis zur Jupiter-Bahn raus. Und das ist ja auch das, was jetzt Rosetta macht. Darum ist man im Winterschlaf, weil wir nicht mehr genug Energie haben. Und wenn es wieder zurückkommt, etwa zu der Empfindung, dann wird es wieder eingeschaltet. Und das ist ungefähr sozusagen die Dimension, auf der sich der Tschurjumow-Gerasimenko bewegt. Und der ist ja wohl auch erst Ende der 40er Jahre eingefangen worden vom Jupiter, also auf diese Bahn gezwungen. Und die sonnenexte Entfernung hat sich auch über die letzten Jahrzehnte ein bisschen verändert. Also die ist immer näher an die Sonne gekommen. Das kann man dazu sagen, wir haben ja die Bahn zurückgerechnet und alles untersucht. Der sonnenexte Punkt ist also nicht genau in der Erdbahnentfernung von der Sonne, sondern ein bisschen weiter draußen, so etwa 1,2. Und dann gehen wir natürlich mit der Bahn wieder raus, Richtung Jupiter, sondern wir fliegen in eine ähnliche Bahn, wie wir jetzt mit dem Rosetta auch fliegen.
Jetzt im Juli 2011 wird also diese Hibernation eingeschaltet?
Also am 8. Juni, das ist unser Ziel jetzt. 8. 8. Juni, ja das ist jetzt festgelegt, das ist also schon bald. Gehen wir in eine Hibernation, das heißt, wir haben jetzt ein... Rosetta ist ja drei Achsen stabilisiert, ist also fest ausgerichtet immer. Und für die Hibernation setzen wir in eine sehr stabile Konfiguration. Wir werden das sozusagen aufspinnen, wie man das sagt. Also wir werden es in Rotation versetzen. Das wird dann also rotationsstabilisiert sein, wie ein Fahrrad oder wie ein Rad, was ja dann eine stabile Lage ist. Wir werden also das... und lassen das dann rotieren. Das ist also das Kritische, dass wir es in eine genau stabile Rotations versetzen und dann lassen wir es gehen.
Also die Rotation ist sozusagen erforderlich, dass man ohne Nachregelung seine......
dass man eine stabile Ausrichtung und eine stabile Bahn hat. Das ist also sozusagen die stabilste Lage.
Wie lange dauert dieser Vorgang?
Also für uns ist sozusagen der 8. Juni, das Wettmorgens, das Aufspielen sind ein paar Stunden bis wir das alles, muss ja alles kontrolliert werden, geht ziemlich langsam. Also das ist eine Größenordnung von dem Schiff.
Und wenn er sich so dreht, dass man das Gefühl hat, okay, alles klar, jetzt passt das, dann sagt man den System, schaltet euch mal ab, spart mal Strom.
Genau, das ist es. Und dann verabschieden wir uns für zweieinhalb Jahre.
Und beobacht, also dann gibt es auch keine Kommunikation.
Es gibt keine Kommunikation in der Zeit. Das haben wir überlegt, das ist still. Nicht weg, es ist still.
Für zweieinhalb Jahre.
Ja, wir machen es am 8. Juni und wir werden es am 20. Januar 2014 wieder aufwecken. Oder es weckt sich selbst. Es ist eine Schaltuhr an Bord und der Wecker wird es dann auflösen. Aber es ist auch so, dass wir von der Erde auch mit Kommandos aufwecken können. Also wir können Kommandos ins Space Park bringen. Sollte der Wecker nicht klingeln? Nicht laut genug. Also es gibt ja moderne Wecker, wo man drei oder vier Zeiten hintereinander. Da ist schon einige Redundanz eingebaut. Das heißt, wenn es beim ersten Mal geht, versucht es mal intern. Das geht schon also ein paar Mal. Und wir werden natürlich gespannt warten. Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, was ich am 20. wenn ich gesund und munter bleibe, am 20. Januar 2014 tue. Fingernägel kurz. Das Herzschlagfinale, ja. Das habe ich bei Giotto einmal mitgemacht. Ich weiß ungefähr, da hatten wir schon Erfahrung. Da saßen wir auch da und haben gewartet. Das war bei Giotto noch komplizierter. Aber ich meine jetzt hier, da weiß ich was, da sitzt man da nervös. Dann kommt die Erleichterung, wenn das Signal wieder da ist. Und wir können also, wenn er nicht gleich aufweckt, dann können wir auch... So wie das Piepsen des Sputniks. So wird es auch sein, ja.
Und dann wird das ein wildes Jahr. Weil im Januar wird er aufgeweckt. Ein paar Monate später ist man schon beim Kometen.
Okay, wir werden es aufwecken, dann wird nochmal den ganzen Check durchgemacht. Und dann werden wir Mitte Mai machen wir das zweite große Manöver. Wir müssen nochmal das endgültige Manöver machen, dass wir wirklich mit der Bahn vom Kometen synchronisiert werden. Und dann geht es Schlag auf Schlag. Dann müssen wir sofort anfangen, das Beobachtungsprogramm durch, um alles zu charakterisieren, dass wir in den Bahn gehen können. Wir müssen für den Länder auch alles vorbereiten, weil den wollen wir Ende des Jahres, also Oktober, November, den Länder auf den Kometen setzen. Das ist einer der nächsten spannenden Augenblicke. Das ist ganz klar. Für viele Leute ist das das große Drama der Mission. Dann zu sitzen und zu sehen, was wir machen wollen, ist sehr einfach. Aber durch das ist es sehr kompliziert, dass wir den Länder gesund und munter auf den Kometen bringen. Das wird die nächste große Spannung werden. Das wird dann spätestens November passieren. Wir wollen das machen, bevor der Komet aktiv wird. Wir wollen, bevor näher die Sonne kommt, dass sich so langsam die Aktivität da hoch führt. Das ist ein Trade-off. Wir wollen uns nicht noch ein bisschen Komplikation einkaufen, dass wir jetzt sagen, warte mal, bis der Action vom Kometen her ist. Wir machen die Action und dann darf der Komet aktiv werden. Da können Sie sich darauf verlassen, dass das wenn heiße anderthalb Jahre. Es ist eine Gelegenheit und wir müssen so viel wie möglich machen. Wir müssen es auch so gut wie möglich machen. Das heißt also nicht übertrieben, nicht alle wünschen, sondern einfach sagen, uns wirklich konzentrieren erst auf das Wichtige und dann immer weitermachen. Das ist kompliziert. Das kann ich gut unterstreiten, dass wir dann heiße anderthalb Jahre. Ich habe da vielleicht viel mehr Zeit, weil ich gerade um den Zeitpunkt auch in Pension gehen werde. Das sage ich dazu. Man hat jetzt so lange dran gearbeitet. Ich habe es ja gesagt von 1985, aber in dieser Mission, da will man das doch nochmal. Das ist fast der Lebensraum der Großen. Man will doch gucken, dass man das so gemacht hat, dass man dann also sagen kann, es hat geklappt.
Kann ich nur alles Glück wünschen, was man für so eine Mission braucht. Gut vorbereitet ist hier auf jeden Fall. Ich sage jetzt mal vielen Dank für die Ausführung zu Rosetta und Giotto. Spannend, mal gucken, ob es ein Matschball ist oder doch ein Schneeball.
Ich glaube, nach Rosetta werden wir wieder viel mehr wissen. Ich werde wahrscheinlich wieder neue Fragen auftun.
Vielleicht haben wir auch noch eine Gelegenheit 2014, wenn das Ding aufgewacht ist, das Ganze noch ein bisschen aus der Nähe zu begleiten.
Ja, das glaube ich, das wird interessant. Wäre schön, wenn Sie es mit einem der Kollegen oder mit mir noch mal unterhalten können und wenn man sich daran erinnert, was man schon mal so ein bisschen diskutiert hat.
Steht ja im Internet, da kann man ja alles nachhören. Vielen Dank. Das war es von Raumzeit zum Thema Rosetta und Giotto. Und sicherlich nicht die letzte Mission, die wir uns ein bisschen genauer anschauen werden. Aber das war es jetzt erstmal für heute. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald bei Raumzeit.